[Music]
let's go to mel in fort worth what's up
mel
hey dr john how are you partying i'm not
partying i'm at work i'm not i don't
know why i say that all the time i'm
doing great how about you
we're doing really good really really
good awesome all right so what's up okay
okay so um my husband and i feel really
strong about being a family that always
tells the truth but in age-appropriate
ways so that we're kind of always
exchanging innocence for wisdom love it
um so we spend a lot of time because my
family lives all over the world we talk
a lot about my family and my husband's
family so my seven-year-old has a really
strong sense of family with relatives he
barely ever sees
and he's also learning our history which
is pretty cool
but the issue that we're now facing is
my son is asking a lot of questions
about my dad
and my husband and i don't know how to
answer his
questions about his death in an
age-appropriate way because
the truth about
his death is really heavy that most
adults
have a really hard time grasping okay
um and for that reason my siblings have
chosen to tell their kids an alternative
ending
um but that doesn't that doesn't fit
right with my husband and i
um
i also feel like i might be a little bit
further along in my healing process with
all of it like i'm really
well and whole and complete in who i am
today
um and i want my son to be able to kind
of see
what can happen on the other side of
living through unimaginable
circumstances okay
so a quick picture of my dad um he was a
child who grew up during the last world
war
um his family managed to escape they
were the first family in many months not
to be shot
leaving behind half of one extended
family and we've never ever talked to
that side ever again
so that really affected him growing up
and then when i was a kid he was finally
diagnosed with being bipolar
he had
psychiatrists he took medication but it
didn't really help at all so living
under his house was very
scary and very unpredictable yeah
and then when i was 17
um he laid out all his personal effects
on the bed
around dinner time because that's when
he knew my mom would call for him
and
he went into the backyard and set
himself on fire
so my husband and i want to be very
careful
and mindful about how we choose to share
this with my son
who's seven and he's
seven i'm a big boy i can know
information i'm really brave mom
i'm not afraid to say that he took his
own life and they had mental illness i
know how to talk about that stuff
it's the follow-up questions
that
we feel really lost on how
how to answer that yeah
so i'm going to answer that really quick
and then we'll circle back okay
yeah the quick of it is
is when you're telling a seven-year-old
something you're not not telling them
you are taking ownership of what you
want to talk about
and you're modeling for them
that you have autonomy over the things
that you want to think about and talk
about which is a gift
it's one of the cornerstones of being
mentally well
and so instead of saying
um you're only seven you're too young
we'll tell you when you get older
instead of saying that
um it is
it's was really painful for mommy
and i'm choosing to not talk about it
right now one day i'll talk about it but
today i'm choosing to not talk about it
and that conversation is over
yeah and that is a gift to your kid
yeah
and kudos to you high five to you
somersaults and cartwheels to you for
not lying to your children there will be
held to pay for your brothers and
sisters choices
and it will come out in weird ways
but a fundamental
piece of their core identity they've
chosen to hide which perpetuates trauma
and
um
when you say they were shot was was
there a history like in concentration
camps
um they uh they uh escaped through a
border through the woods okay and mike
yeah so the studies were actually done
on that community
that lived through that mess
yeah discuss
generational trauma that comes from
just
living and breathing and drinking the
water of pure evil which is what people
who survived the holocaust the whole
mess had to do
and
um and so there's there
yeah they're kicking the can down the
road
and good to for you guys for not so
you're gonna balance that with
um by the way i the language i would use
is daddy um
you're my dad granddad died by suicide
which is different than he took his own
life right
dad died by suicide he's very very sick
and
i don't really want to talk about it
anymore well how what did he do i don't
choose to talk about that right now one
day i will but it still makes me very
sad and i'm just going to end it right
there
i'm not going to apologize i'm not gonna
explain or whatever and you are teaching
your child a powerful lesson there
um circling back
lighting yourself on fire
is
a middle finger
is it not yeah
yeah it was it was totally he was
practicing the day before the neighbor
saw small fires in the day it was a big
f u because my siblings and i all put
down boundaries with him because he was
so toxic and unwell
um
that i had stopped talking to him a year
and a half before he died and we live in
the same house because he was just so
unhealthy yeah and um and
you're you're healed from that
yeah
yeah good yeah i'm totally healed from
that i just you're able to talk to me
about it your heart's not beating faster
right now yeah no like i'm
i'm i want to be able to tell my son the
truth because
who i am on the other side of this is is
pretty
unusual so let me tell you this here
here's the important and i know i'm
asking you to walk a razor's edge here
this is hard okay yeah
don't make your need to tell
a burden that your child has to carry
absolutely okay and there's a fine line
there between i don't want to tell the
truth and he can't know this because
he's only seven and he does not need a
picture of a burning man in the backyard
um he doesn't need that in his head okay
one day you can have that hard
conversation that's a that's a much
later in life hard conversation yes i
agree but do you have any guidance for
when i when we have that conversation
because we're not he's not
age-appropriate now yeah exactly um i
would
kind of thinking about it like a like a
gas pedal i'm slowly or maybe depressing
the gas pedal or slowly letting the gas
off right so i'm gonna start with daddy
died my dad died and i don't choose to
talk about it when they're three or four
and maybe six or seven or eight
depending on the wisdom of a child that
every kid is differently i have
different conversations with my son than
i do with my daughter just do right
and um death for my daughter was pretty
abstract
late until i mean she was
five or six
my son's beloved dog died when he was
three and a half
and we took that dog out into my buddy's
ranch and we dug the hole ourselves and
we prayed over that dog and we sung to
that dog and we talked about it and we
buried that dog together my son had a
visceral experience with death when he
was three and a half
and what was beautiful was that was a
touchstone for us for years still is
remember how and then we went to the
first funeral
but when does granddad get up remember
back with maria the dog
um grandma's not going to get up cause
he's passed away he's dead now and so we
were able to like oh okay right so it
became a touchdown became an important
part my daughter
i wasn't going to kill something just to
show her a dead body right and yeah her
first experience was a funeral and that
was that's been hard for her because
she's told me i still see that picture
my son doesn't have that he didn't have
that replay she does and so i know i'm
gonna be a little more sensitive as she
gets older but then maybe 12 15 16
somebody in your son's life might die by
suicide right or somebody's parent might
pass
then it will be was it a gun no it was a
pretty violent it was pretty rough for
us to watch it was hard
really hard it was very graphic and
again i'm still not going to say that
i'm thinking 16 17 18 before i say they
lit themselves on fire
right yeah absolutely and that's gonna
be mental health like i wanna make sure
my kids are okay and they are not
struggling with anxiety or depression or
or or right i might also begin to give
them a context of their history here's
some of the things that granddad
experienced
right yeah
and what you'll like here's some stories
or here's uh like a children's book
about or here's some of grandma's
letters or something like that we're
going to create a
whole
i don't want to tell the story by itself
in isolation does that make sense
yes i want to tell the story as a
continuing narrative of here's the life
here's the the family tree from which
you come from
yeah and you can handle you can not deal
with the trauma and you can be so buried
underneath it and not get help and not
do the xyz
and
or
mommy put in the work mommy worked
really really really hard and this is
what healing can look like see what i'm
saying
yeah i feel like we've done a pretty
good job of leaving enough breadcrumbs
um to get a picture and a sense of a lot
of the stuff it's just we've we've he's
asked and i said it's complicated and um
i'm just not ready to talk about that
with you yet and you know i won't lie to
you i'll always tell you the truth but
there's just some things that aren't you
know
i'll tell you when we're ready tell him
that makes you feel
so he knows he's not crazy tell him it
still makes mommy sad
yeah tell me that when i was when mommy
was was a child how old were you
uh when he died he was 17. i was 17.
yeah tell her that mommy was still a
child when it happened i was still a kid
and it made mommy very scared
and very sad and i don't want to talk
about it right now
and the idea that he's that would give
him permission to be sad and to be
scared about things because my mommy was
look how tough she is now you see what
i'm saying
so tell him how you feel not just
don't make it a math problem make it a
human problem
yeah
which is i i can't tell you he's so
lucky to have you
man what a gift
such a blessing man it's awesome um no
dude you're you're yeah you're doing it
great and the idea that you're
giving him a picture of what healing
looks like oh we
man it's hard the road you've been down
is hard hard hard and let me tell you
this
as he approaches 17
14 15 16 it wouldn't surprise me if your
body starts settling the alarms don't be
afraid to continue to stay well and to
continue to do the things that you need
to do to stay well and to get ahead of
things
um if i'm you when he turns 13 14 i'm
probably gonna go make an appointment
with a counselor just to do it just
check in
get the engine run over right checked
over
but i'm gonna be about modeling what
wellness looks like and healing looks
like because your body's going to set
off on you again when it remembers like
i remember this i remember this let's
get ahead of that thing and continue to
paint such a beautiful picture of
healing
um and man
just so you know this
generationally down the road
people are gonna live differently
because of the work you're putting in
right now such a gift